you know you joined the panel
mixed reviews I got food yeah I got food
let's talk about it I loved it I thought
it was fabulous I felt like a wrestler
because wrestlers get booed right you're
right I grew up watching wrestling and
to me I was like you know 32 years in
this business I was like oh my god I've
never been booed wow I thought it was
kind of cool I loved it what were you
hoping to clear up well I'm not here I
don't think you're here to clear
anything up but bravocon you're just
here to tell the truth and have a good
time right I mean I I'm here for the
fans we're here for the fans the fans
are amazing except for the ones that
booed me
um no I they're all amazing and coming
out of the reunion what was the most
challenging part for you
well it's just a really free Union the
challenging part was just to like
continue on you know yeah
um
that I just got through it things that I
literally just am standing here today
and I got through it you know grief was
a very
tricky and um you have to continue to
live and I did